hello everybody and welcome to episode
13 of my paper flipping series we're
gonna go from zero to hundred mil using
the grand exchange only today we are
starting at about fifteen point one mil
that's not too bad we're hoping to get
to 20 ml before the end of the week I'm
not sure if that's gonna happen or not
but we'll try our best
that's enough in the intro let's get
started okay so first up we're gonna do
the fire or bat has a really a thirty GP
margin on it and it has a ten thousand
GP limit but we're gonna do 5k it's
think because I would use up quite a bit
every money okay no we're gonna do seven
thousand and next up we're gonna do the
water orb actually and the fire were
about a good margin so does the water
orb
looks like has over forty again the
water orbs traded pretty frequently so
we'll go ahead and do that we'll just
probably use the rest of our money and
we'll see how many can afford probably
three or four thousand little less than
three thousand looks like okay well
we'll see how these orbs work out okay
so the orbs have been flipped and it's
pretty disappointing to be honest oh
yeah well the water orbs we got a forty
GP margin on and 651 of those gives us
26 K fire orbs I don't even know it's
something worth tackling it's probably
ten to fifteen K at best so pretty lame
unfortunately we didn't buy enough T's
for this to be worth it at all so hope
we didn't lose any money okay so we're
gonna do the dragon axe again that this
items have worked pretty well for us
action in the past it has a 40 GP power
40 yeah quanti limit but you can
generally get to 3k on it which is
pretty nice and with the rest of our
money I think we're gonna do some raw
shark head about a 15 GP Marilyn I
believe so we'll go ahead and use the
rest of her money can't afford ten
thousand but wouldn't get eight or nine
K at least I will see if an 8k war and
yeah okay we'll see you how these go
so we have sold most of the dragon axes
in all of the raw sharks and for the
amount we bought that actually worked
out pretty well the raw sharks we got a
10 GP margin which is pretty awesome for
how many are traded every day so 10 GP
times a decay would give us 80k the
dragon axes we actually have a 7k Marjan
we only got 13 axes but still I gave us
90 K and we still have two more to sells
so pretty good actually
okay we've been spending so long trying
to find an item but we're gonna try the
chocolate dust again actually has a 8 GP
margin on it
yeah 8 and yeah that's pretty awesome
for the price again I'm not sure I'm
gonna trade it every day but I think
it's a couple hundred thousand for here
as well try to get the buying limit
worth of it
and yeah we'll see how that goes and
next up we're gonna do another kind of
weird item we're gonna do the gold and
unstrung which has a 15 GP margin on it
just quite good again for the price I
know these have a couple million trade
every day so you think these we've done
trade quickly but I've had experiences
in past but they have not actually
bought and sold very quick but we'll see
that goes this time
so again will do with you buying them
worth of it which apparently is 18,000
that's what we'll give that a try and
last up we're gonna do the green dragon
house I think it only has a 20 GP margin
and it is a 2,000 GP item but again
these will be very quick so we'll see
how much we can make on a quick flip
like this I will hopefully wouldn't get
dozens of them a couple thousand I guess
we're gonna get like not that many will
go for 5000 I think we I'm really really
bad at adding stuff up sometimes I don't
lunch but put it down to 5,000 and then
we can get on with our day as I said the
chocolate dust and the gold analyst
weird items they did not work at all
sweet only really God to green dragon
Heights which actually did work pretty
decently we got a 24 GP margin on each
one and 5,000 those gives us 120 K we
didn't get a substantial amount of
either the chocolate that circle the
amulet so we're not really gonna
calculate a flip for that because it
pretty negligible even if we do make any
money I'll be yeah let's try again so I
think we actually do the crystal key
again looks like it has 1.7 pay per key
combined which is quite high before was
normal yet um so we'll go ahead and use
the rest of your money just to buy some
keys probably break down to being a
couple hundred each we'll have to see
though I do like doing the crystal keys
but it can make for a very messy flip
because unless all of them buy perfectly
and sell combine and sell right away
it's really hard to kind of visualize at
least for you guys to see how much money
I'm actually making so I try not to do
it too often but it seems to be a pretty
good price so we'll go ahead and see him
and we'll start with the tooth half the
keys I will try maybe 350 or 400 I think
400 might be too much though I don't
know about that we'll have to see if we
can actually afford enough of them and
I'll go to the loo paths we're gonna buy
them for is think somewhere on 8989
t2 and oh just quite not enough so we'll
just pull this lower down to 380 or
something and yeah then we'll just
combine 380 worth of the keys I really
feel like taking the other offer at this
point so we've actually sold the keys
and majid an even higher margin than we
started with
we ended up getting about 2.2 K on each
key and we got 193 keys Vaness 386 K
which is pretty good we didn't get an
even amount so we did sell back the
extra blue paths of a key but we
actually made about 500 each one of
those as well so we're probably gonna
know 10 11 K from that so pretty much we
got 400 K from that flip so again the
keys do work pretty well um when the
price is right anyway as you can see
there the Mithra or has a 12 GP margin
on it which is quite nice so I think
we're gonna buy a buying limits worth
need to come up with a unit of
measurement for the buying limits worth
of item anyway we'll go ahead and I
think it's 13,000 so we'll go ahead and
buy a 13,000 412 GP margin should give
us well
I'm over 100k and that's for sure and
once again the dragon axe has a 2k
margin and I believe it is pretty good
so we'll go ahead and buy another 40 of
these and hopefully get a DK or so so
the black mask has a 12 K margin and we
actually did check ourselves just by
buying and selling one and we did this
once in the challenge video survey and
tried again hopefully we can get to all
10 of them well 9 now but still that
should give us a hefty profit of a 100
plus K still so that's pretty nice okay
so the flips are in now the real hero
here is the mithril or we did not make
any money on anything else really
and surprisingly the mistral or we got a
18 GPA margin on in 13,000 of those
would give us 234 K which is insane for
how quickly this item is traded so I
would I would definitely give mr. or
Shah Hut the margin still like this it
only took an hour to flip that without
234 K which is awesome black mask I mean
we did we didn't break even on that we
sold sold a bat for 582 K but not much
there oh yeah and sorry we actually did
flip a super attack potion for 84k how
much pretty good but we made about 325 K
or so so the methyl or still has an 11
GP margin on it which is still very good
for what kind of item it is so we'll go
ahead and do another 13,000 oh it's for
sure and hopefully we'll still make over
a hundred K from it and lastly here I
think we're gonna try the dragon
scimitar I mean it only has a 900 GP
marg on it but again this should be very
quick and hopefully we can buy a hundred
or so of them I have not checked the
buying limits we're gonna quickly do
that now
yeah actually didn't can't find one for
it so we'll go ahead and try buying
maybe well we'll just use the rest of
our money now which would be like I
don't know like I mean 3060 perfect
right 70 her got it and we have
successfully sold everything so for this
final flip of the episode I believe we
pretty good yeah dragon scimitars we got
I kept the 900 GP margin on giving us
about 61 K in total and the myth rollers
were quite good again giving us a 11 GP
margin and about 810 K in total that we
made and we also did some super energies
giving this a DGP on each one in 2000
flipped would give us 160 K so when told
him probably another 300 K and so today
we didn't make any crazy flips but we
made some steady progress we started at
about fifteen point one mil and we're
ending the boat sixteen point six so
maybe 1.5 mil and this is over the
course of only three days so I'm pretty
happy with that and can't really record
much more because it's so damn hot my
computer will probably shut off and
explode so well thanks for watching guys
I will see you guys next week
you